fue el primer país en adoptar el
refuerzo de la vacuna anti kobe y este
martes el ministro de salud de israel
dijo que 4 de los 95 millones de
personas que forman parte de su
población ya han recibido su tercera
dosis de momento el refuerzo se
administra para mayores de 65 pero
pronto estará a disposición de todos los
ciudadanos a esta política se atribuye
el haber podido superar la cuarta ola un
estudio a gran escala publicado el mes
pasado mostró que la tercera dosis en
israel- tuvo una efectividad de 92 por
ciento en prevenir las formas más graves
de la enfermedad comparada con personas
que sólo recibieron dos dosis de facer
biotech los datos del estudio también
revelaron una eficacia de 81 por ciento
en prevenir las muertes relacionadas con
el cob y de hecho sólo hubo siete
decesos entre los participantes que
recibieron el refuerzo comparado con los
44 de los que no lo tienen ambos grupos
de pruebas registraron una reducción
significativa de las hospitalizaciones y
muertes en comparación con los que no se
han vacunado en absoluto a pesar de las
cifras el gobierno sigue cauteloso y
atribuye a su reserva a los no vacunados
y a las nuevas variantes aún con esta
campaña de vacunación escala no creo que
podamos decir que estamos a salvo del
quinto brote que podría darse en el
invierno israel debate ahora sí debe
aprobar o no la inmunización de niños de
5 a 11 años una decisión que podría
tomarse en las próximas semanas